jetzt machen wir noch ein spiel rate mal
wer bin ich ich bin klein und dick
stimmt und impertinenz recht hause
ok meine mutter arbeitet als frisörin
weiß jetzt schon oder
ich helfe meiner mutter ruhig nur kann
jetzt weiß das aber ich bin der beste in
der klasse jetzt war es das gleiche
ich fahre den ferien alleine nach berlin
ist das emil und die detektive die war
friseurin meine güte doch mal beim
haarewaschen geholfen
ich bin eine frau eine adelige aus dem
russland des 19 jahrhunderts anna
karenina genau
okay ich bin 22 jahre alt
ja ich besuche mein vetter joachim sagt
noch weiter ich schwärme für eine russin
mit nachlässigen manieren
die erinnert mich an einen von fern
geliebten mitschüler von dem ich einmal
ein bleistift lee ich gerate in den
berühmtesten schneesturm der
literaturgeschichte ich bin die
hauptfigur ja hoch sagt man die erste
hans castro hat kost ob ich bin dann
fielen etwa zu die ja ich weiß jetzt
bist du kannst mich jetzt schlagen mit
meinen eigenen waffen also also ich bin
ehrlich gesagt ziemlich geschädigt
dazu sage ich jetzt nicht ich sag mal
stichwort prothesen das leben hat mich
kalt und gefühllos gemacht und jetzt
komme ich zurück in meine heimat um mich
zu rächen
dieses gewicht wenigstens einmal sehe
ich ein ratloses gesicht
ich möchte meinen ex mann tot sehen mehr
informationen braucht es eigentlich gar
nicht ich sehe was ich bin ich komme
zurück nach kühlen gott ich bin die alte
dame ja aber wie hier sie erklärt zorn
asiens anna kowski seiner sie irgendwie
sachen asya das klavier gelten lassen
jetzt habe ich nichts mehr